president trump's attorney joining us
with more reaction eric trump is with us
eric you were with your dad that morning
that day a week ago
let's go through what you know and
now these new developments but i also
want you to stand back and look at the
six year history that i just laid out
here i mean you have you have a guy by
the name of peter strzok saying we will
stop him
this is in the summer
of 2016 leading into your father's
election
then uh if your plan doesn't work uh
don't worry we have an insurance policy
it's like if you're if you've the
unlikelihood that you die before if
you're 40 or below 40. he actually said
that none of these people that signed
these fives warrants were ever held
accountable how do we how can we say we
have equal justice in this country and
all those people got away with it
well we can't sean because we we don't
and you know the one thing i'll tell you
it's caused the greatest fundraising my
father's poll numbers have absolutely
gone through the roof they're not even
talking about any other republican
candidates because they've all kind of
you know disappeared they're not even in
the equation i mean last night i had an
argument between two people in a
restaurant who are trying to buy laura
and i dinner to apologize to what the
you know for what the united states
government
has done to our family sean i mean you
wouldn't believe the energy out there
i've been through all of these fire
storms over the year i've never seen
america more mad than it is right now
there's only so many times you can cry
wolf people are not buying this sham in
the country they see the weaponization
of the fbi they're calling it the police
state in this country
people get this for what it is sean the
you know they've removed the wool from
people's eyes and people know exactly
what's going on they're targeting donald
trump they're targeting his family
they're targeting everybody around him
they're targeting his lawyers uh anybody
that's close to donald trump anybody
who's effective they're targeting right
now and people understand this for
exactly what it's worth
i named all of the names all the people
that signed the fisa warrant i i read
the text of peter strzok and lisa page
uh i read the list of every conservative
associated with your dad and these
pre-dawn raids guns drawn in some cases
the media tipped off so they can capture
it all on camera at 5 45 in the morning
how convenient
and now your own your own father's home
has been raided and they just started
taking boxes out randomly and
and going through melania's wardrobe
apparently uh as well
and the question is back in june your
father offered to give them everything
isn't that true the room that they asked
him the padlock which he
agreed to
yeah that's exactly right sean my father
has been so cooperative i mean and
that's what doesn't make sense the whole
family my father said anything you guys
need let me know
anything you need you know let us know
like
i mean the lawyer when i first told him
about this he goes i can't believe this
like we had the greatest relationship
with these people your father literally
was with them in earlier by the way they
put that in writing it all you let us
know and we'll give it to you they put
that in writing in february of last year
of this year february of this year they
said you've been so cooperative so this
really isn't about isn't this really
about
a
a fishing expedition january 6 taxes or
anything else you know if your father
spit on the sidewalk isn't that what
they're really looking for
absolutely it's a fishing expedition i
mean they pulled the warrant on friday
they didn't actually execute the warrant
until monday so when i hear about these
nonsense speculations about nuclear
codes okay so you know fbi agents were
so busy on a weekend that you know over
nuclear codes they waited four days i
mean it's nonsense sean is absolutely
fishing and you know it's the exact same
playbook that they use during russia the
exact same reporters
are being leaked information that were
used as the sources for the whole russia
hoax i mean go line up all the reporters
who were getting inside information
unsolicited information during the
russia hoax they're the exact same
people that the fbi are leaking to now
it's the same reporters reporting on the
same thing the same story
they're going to their friends in the
democratic media who are effectively the
lobbyist arm of the democratic party and
they're leaking stories about donald
trump
90 days out sean from the midterms it's
not it's not surprising this timing is
not surprising and it's backfiring on
these people
will you you still have the surveillance
tape is that correct will you are you
allowed to share that with the country
absolutely sean at the right time and
your body cam point was spot on that's
why cops wear body cams they don't tell
you to turn off cameras they want
transparency and that's not what
happened here
and you know for a fact they asked for
the cameras to be turned off
they asked for the cameras to be turned
off
wow all right eric trump
unbelievable times thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else